Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm sorry about... I'm still using the shitty mic, or, like, I don't know.
It's not a shitty mic, it's a shirt mic, but, like, there's something wrong with it because it makes the sound, so I'm sorry that I now, like, made you guys pay attention to it now, so now you're like, oh my god, I can't unhear it.
Oh my god, why did you say that, Doki?
I lived in such an oblivious life, not noticing the sound that comes out when you use that mic.
Now I hear it all the time now!
I can't help but notice it all the time!
Okay, you guys don't hear it?
Oh, thank god, it might be my BGM.
Um, my BGM might be hiding the sound right now, or it might have fixed it, I don't know.
I could be gaslighting, I don't know.
Typical Doki, gaslighting.
I knew that Google Doki was, was real.
Boy, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Welcome back, Doki!
Missed you my addiction!
Thank you!
Can we not?
I knew it!
I, yes, I can, uh, make jokes about it now because, uh, I, I've, like, moved past it.
I finally had my Google Doki archive.
Now I can't make jokes- Okay, I know you guys are like, now that you had to do a Google Doki, you can't make jokes about it anymore.
You can't make fun of other people for doing Google Doki's.
But I can!
Because I have nothing else in my life.
I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I Thank you for the magenta soupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Donkey bird!
By the way, I called out that weird noise months ago.
Months!
Thank you for the magenta soupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, but...
I don't know why it makes that sense.
I assume it's my mic because it is quite old.
I got this like years ago.
So like this mic is quite old.
Um, and um...
I upgraded it to...
I don't even know what I upgraded it to.
I don't know anything about mics, guys.
I saw like all the suggestions.
And then I told my sound guy.
And I was like, what do I get?
And they're like, oh, it's a Newman TLM 102 condenser microphone.
Which could be...
It's not a cable issue.
My cable is like pretty good for my microphone.
I know for...
It's not a mic...
It's not a cable issue.
It's uh...
It's um...
I think it's a microphone issue for sure.
Uh...
So...
I...
I hope it is.
Because I bought an expensive microphone for it.
Uh...
So I hope it is.
Um...
But yes...
Uh...
I was away for an entire week.
Um...
Because I finally had my Google Doki arc.
And at that...
And also I had to take care of dad.
Dad's home, by the way, guys.
Um...
Dad's home.
And uh...
Uh...
I think it...
Oh, so by the way...
Uh...
I think it just has to do with the fact that my mic has like stuff on.
Like you know like...
Fluff on it.
So like...
I assume that's why it's like...
Whatever.
It's something to do with my mic.
Um...
But yes...
Doki Amber Doge is home now.
And, um, I had to, you know, adjust my schedule to take care of him.
And, uh, because he has his own schedule now.
I have to walk him three times a day versus the usual two times a day.
Uh, and then so I have to slowly readjust to it.
And also, like, he has a...
Okay, this little fucker, he has a special kidney diet now that he has to eat.
Um, which is wet food.
You know, he is so happy.
He is so fucking happy that, yeah, his kidneys are failing.
And if we skip what if we...
By the way, so, um, so, yeah, he...
Yeah, so he...
And I can only buy this particular wet food because it's, like, a specially prescribed veterinarian food for kidney diets.
So, like, uh, I can only get this food at the veterinarian.
So, and it's, like, canned food.
Canned wet food.
So, he's a little special boy right now.
He's a fancy dog at the moment.
Um, and because, uh, he also, every day, he needs to have this specific medication for his kidneys.
Um, because I forgot what his...
I don't remember what the kidney...
I mean, they gave me a document saying what it is.
Uh, but, like, obviously, I don't remember what thing...
What he has on the top of my head.
I should remember it on the top...
I'm getting pen insurance.
I need to figure out how to get pen insurance.
I...
I need to...
I need to figure out how to get pen insurance.
Because I need to get prescription for this fucking kidney medication.
And, um, his wet food.
He's like, ooh la la.
I get wet food now every single day.
Ooh la la.
Ah, because my kidneys are failing.
Okay, his kidneys aren't failing, by the way.
It's just that he's peeing out protein.
And so, he has, like, um...
He has a medication to make sure that he doesn't pee out more of his protein.
So, he's like, ooh la la.
My kidneys are so fucked up.
But I get to have wet food.
If I skip my medication, I could potentially have a stroke.
Ooh la la.
Yippee.
Wet food diet.
Yum yum.
Yippee.
Worth it.
Fancy boy.
Okay, why are you...
Okay, not maybe a day, guys.
Not a day.
It's more so, like...
Okay, apparently for dogs, um...
A stroke for dogs are, like, different from strokes for humans.
So, when a...
I don't know what it...
I don't know what it means.
But, like, they were like, oh yeah, um...
Just make sure he has this medication and monitor him.
And medication.
And he should be fine.
But, like...
Because it's, like, basically, if he pees out too much of his protein, he would, like...
His brain will go funny.
Uh...
His brain will go really funny if he pees too much protein.
So, like...
So, I have to make sure he has his medication and he eats...
Has his fancy wet food diet.
So, he doesn't pee out all his protein.
So, yeah.
I...
I don't know.
Um...
But he's happy, at least.
Uh...
At least...
At least he's, like, really, really happy that he gets to live the life right now.
Um...
By the way, he is now not allowed on top of my bed.
I bought, like, three ramps and I positioned it all around my bed.
Because that's literally the only place he could jump off and, like, try to jump on my bed.
So, I've got three ramps to place around my bed.
And you know what the...
Okay.
It freaked me the fuck out.
Because two days ago, um...
Um...
He heard a knock on the door because I ordered, like, delivery.
And then he jumped off the bed when the ramp was next to him.
Like, literally...
Okay.
Not even next to him.
It was, like, in...
The ramp was in front of him.
But he decided to jump off the bed next to the ramp.
And I was like, are you fucking...
And then I never let him on top.
And then after that, I moved all the ramps off the bed.
And it was the first day...
The first time he finally grew the courage to walk up the bed.
Because he had, like, PTSD.
He had PTSD over, like, going up the stairs on...
Going up the ramp on the bed.
Because, you know, that's where he fucking broke his back.
And...
That, like, literally that's how he broke his back.
So...
From, like, jumping off of the bed.
So, he had, like, PTSD from, like, walking up...
Like, you know...
Walking up the ramp to the bed.
And two days ago was the first time he finally was like, I'm a brave boy.
Like, he stood at the edge of the ramp.
And he's like, do I go up or do I not go up?
And then finally, he had the courage to go up the bed.
And he was so happy.
And he instantly crawled under my blankets and went to sleep next to me.
And then I was like, oh my god!
Dad, you're so brave!
I finally beat your trauma!
And then literally, two to three hours later, there was a knock on the door.
And he jumped off the bed.
And now he's not allowed to...
He's like, I conquered my trauma!
I'm unstoppable now!
Now I can do anything!
Even jump down!
And then...
So now I've moved all the ramps off my bed.
So I bought...
I spent money on three ramps for no fucking reason!
Yippee!
This is where your super chat money went to!
Yay!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I thought...
I thought I could fix...
And you know what's even worse?
I tried to teach him with the tree.
You know, like...
Worth it!
I like...
You know, okay.
So like, you teach your dog to do the thing.
Where you put him up the stairs and then put him down the stairs.
So I did that.
I was like, here's the food.
Go up the stairs.
Now go down the stairs.
Also, matcha!
Welcome to Tomato Fire!
Welcome, welcome!
And I did that.
And I was like, yay!
You're learning!
And he unlearned it.
He unlearned the going down part.
He...
He could...
He has not...
He unlearned the going...
So I can't risk it.
Obviously, I can't fucking risk it.
Because I feel like he's gonna fucking forget again.
I can't pay another 10 grand for surgery number two.
He does not have that privilege.
I'm sorry.
It's like those billionaires that spend millions of dollars taking heart.
80-year-old billionaires spending millions of dollars taking heart transplants from young people being paid a win.
I can't do that for him.
I am sorry.
Like, I... At some point, he cannot keep... We cannot keep fixing his back.
Like, once is enough, guys.
Once is enough.
That's pretty privileged.
He just wants to be a silly billy.
Chotto, welcome to TomatoFarm.
Welcome, welcome.
Um, Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rap number four.
Toma, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fancy food money.
Ian, welcome.
Thank you, though.
I'm gonna chat the super.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's to the dad jar.
Um, but yeah.
That was basically, um, how dad's doing at the moment.
Um, and, uh, I've been taking him to our dog park.
Um, that was near me because that's even closer to me rather than the usual.
So, there's a dog park near where I live that's, like, uh, um, that was recently built.
And, but, and it's, like, easily accessible to, like, where I am so I don't have to actually go out to get there.
And, like, the really... Okay, so, like, I bought a harness for him because in the past I used to... I just used, like, neck and leash.
Um, and, because, like, he wouldn't... He doesn't pull on his... He doesn't pull on his leash.
So, like, that's why I felt, like, confident.
Like, because usually you don't do that.
But, like, he never pulled on his leash.
So, I was, like, okay.
And he hated harnesses.
So, dad hated harnesses.
So, I never... I tried... I tried to give him harnesses when he was growing up.
But he fucking hated it.
So, I was, like, okay.
Neck and leash.
Because he doesn't pull.
So, I was, like, okay.
We can... We can make this work.
Um, also, by the way, Juan George, thank you for that magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome back, overqualified beto2.
Last week is my birthday.
Can you give me a happy birthday?
Also, how about lower your bet?
Thank you, magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Juan George.
Say happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Um, I am not gonna sacrifice my sleeping arrangements.
Just so he can... He has... By the way, I also bought two more beds for him.
Because one in my office and one next to my bed.
So, like, he does not need the privilege of sleeping on my bed.
Like... So, it's fine.
I'd rather he doesn't break... I'd rather he doesn't break his back.
So, like, I'd rather do that.
Like...
Um... Anyway... Oh, what was I talking about before my mind got, like, everywhere?
Oh... Oh, so, Mr. Sam, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Dad has been a trooper and I hope this Akasupa finds his way to him.
May dad be blessed with the best food he can get and all the quality time.
With the babysitter.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Um... I have a funny story about the dog sitter.
Uh... But let me write this down so I can remember.
Tell story about dogs... Oh, yeah!
The harness.
So... Um... But, obviously, um... I didn't want to put the collar... Like, you know, just the collar and leash on his neck.
Um... Because, obviously, he just... He's still recovering.
He's going through, like, uh... He can't really run.
He does, like, little hops instead of actually running.
Um... And he can't... When he walks, it's, like, slanted.
So, like, he can't walk in a straight line because he's still, like, you know, recovering from his back surgery.
Um... And...
So, um... What I do is that I go no leash and just let him walk to the dog park.
Um... Because, like, uh... He knows how to go there.
He knows how to... Yeah, he drifts now.
So, he knows how to get to the dog park.
And, like... So, he... I just let him walk over there.
And, um...
So, this dog park... Um... This dog park... There's this giant white dog that sometimes shows up at this dog park.
And, um... The thing is... He's not afraid... I talked about it in the members before.
He does... He doesn't, like... He's not afraid of this white... Giant white dog there.
Um... Instead... Um... He rolls over... And becomes a submissive little...
A little bitch.
And... And... And... And... The thing is... He doesn't do that to any other dog.
It's... And then... That giant white... Dog... Fucking... Just licks his ear.
And it's... It's so weird.
It's... Is that like... And he... It's not like he, like... The white dog approaches him.
No.
He... Walks over to the... And he...
He, like... Is so excited, too.
I'm like... Is this... Like... Okay.
I'll show you... Like... This is what he... This is... He rolls over fully on his back.
He's like... Yes.
Lick me.
Oh my god.
He's... Freaky.
He's like... Yes.
Lick me.
And I'm... I... I don't know what to do.
I...
That... What a freak.
And... So... But he likes it even more... When the giant white dog... Licks his ears.
And... I think... Ahem... He's... Freakier than us.
And... And then like... You know... When... The other dog... Walks away... He obviously... He's like... No.
Don't leave!
He... Like...
He gets back and then he like runs up to the other dog and is like, please!
And then he like rolls back on his stomach and is like, lick me!
Or me, oh freak.
And so like, I don't know, I think it's weird.
And then the owner was like, I'm sorry, my dog really loves licking ears for some reason.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, my dog is apparently really into that too.
So that's like status update on what he's going through right now.
He's just like me.
So I'll give you a cute picture of him.
This is like, he's like at my bedroom right now sleeping.
I mean, he usually just sleeps, but there he is.
Tucked in the corner.
Look, he also can tuck himself.
Since he's a wiener dog, they sound like a great match.
Don't can't shame them.
Lexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There he is.
He tucked himself to sleep, by the way, guys.
Since like, wiener dogs love to burrow.
So they know how to like tuck themselves in.
And then sometimes he sleeps like a person and it's a little weird.
But like, I let him do his thing.
Uh, oh, he's so tiny.
Okay.
Okay, so I...
So, okay, the dog sitter story.
Okay, so...
Um, the dog sitter sent me a video of like him...
Um, recovering.
And then...
Wait, okay.
I'm gonna...
Give me a sec.
Let me...
I'm gonna like not move for a sec.
Let me send this video to myself.
Um, so I can show it to you guys.
Because it was a fucking...
I was like, what the fuck?
My dog says like, oh yeah, I forgot to send you this...
Uh, I forgot to send you this video.
Dino was funny.
It was pretty funny though.
It was...
It was pretty funny.
But let me...
Let me save it.
Let me save this and send it over to myself real quick.
So I can show it to you guys.
Um, but the thing is...
She put...
Um, okay, so I'm muting...
I'm gonna like...
I...
Um, the music is not on.
But like, she put a song over this video.
And I was like...
The song choice for the video was like...
It was...
I...
I just did not expect it.
I did not expect the song that...
I...
I need to remember what it was.
Let me see if I can find it.
Alright, give me a sec, guys.
I'm gonna say I can find this particular song that, uh...
My dog sitter used.
Cause I was honestly...
I was not expecting this particular song.
Let me see...
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna say I can find it real quick for...
So I can...
Um...
Alright, let me see what song this is.
It was...
Oh my god.
What was it?
Oh, is it...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Give me a...
I'm sorry.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need to find this.
I need to figure out what song this is.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's not playing.
No!
Okay, wait.
I'm not gonna move for a sec.
I know how to find it.
Sorry, a little intermission.
Guys, a little...
A little...
A little inter...
This is very...
No, you don't understand.
This is very important.
Okay, let me see.
I, like, removed the song for it.
So that's why, like, you don't hear it when I put it on.
But I need a no.
Okay, it's...
Bitch, I'm cute.
So, like...
The song that was playing on this particular video...
Was, bitch, I'm cute.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Why was this playing?
So...
Okay, wait.
Um...
Okay, so...
So...
This was...
This was the song that was...
They...
This was like...
This was, like, what they sent me.
And then the song was...
Bitch, I'm cute.
So...
They were like...
And he's just licking...
He's just licking a cat of alcohol.
I was like...
What the fuck?
And he's just licking the cat.
I was like, what is he doing?
But, like, the BGM of that video was bitch, I'm cute.
And I was like, by the way, the dog sitter...
Okay, let me see if it's this song.
I'm gonna see.
Okay.
This was the song that was playing.
I'll send it to you guys.
This...
This was the song that was playing while I was watching that video.
And...
I was like, what the...
And by the way, the dog sitter is like a 50-year-old mom.
The dog sitter is like a 50-year-old mom with two teenagers.
And obviously, the husband is there, too.
With, like...
With two teenagers.
And...
So, I just not...
I was not expecting it at all.
Um...
Uh, Sportball.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki telling funny stories while laughing.
Missed sentences like the Maple Leafs in Game 7.
They can't finish worth the time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She's just trying to be a hip mom.
I...
I guess.
I fucking...
I fucking guess.
She's trying to be cool for her children.
You know?
For her kids.
Um...
Oh, she's a cool mom.
But yeah, I wanted to, like, give you guys a little dad update.
Oh, it was a little dad update.
It was, like, a 30-minute dad update.
I was a little idiot.
Uh, but yes.
I have to walk dad three times a day now.
And he has, like, a strict routine.
Well, he doesn't...
Okay, that's a lie.
It's not strict.
It's not even...
Like, it's not a strict routine.
It's, like, he has a routine now that I have to keep track of.
And if I don't follow it, he'll just walk over there and, like, be like...
Be like, wake up!
I need feed time!
Also, but, like, he's given up morning feed time.
Because the dog sitters...
The dog sitters used to feed him at 8.30 in the morning.
And, obviously, that's not gonna happen.
That's never gonna happen on my side.
So, like, he has tried...
Uh...
He's tried several times.
Like, I think, like, two to three times.
Uh, to, like, wake me up.
Um, at 8.30 in the morning.
Sometimes 9, you know?
He gives me, like, a little 30-minute breather.
But, I just don't wake up.
And he's, like...
What I've noticed is that he has definitely given up.
I'm trying to...
He has...
He has given up trying to wake me up that early.
Because when I don't get up...
Like, I acknowledge...
The thing is...
I, like, acknowledge that he wants to eat at 8.30.
But I don't get out of my bed.
So, like...
He'll be, like...
Like, you know, really loud.
And then...
I, like...
Obviously, I look at him.
And he's, like...
And then I, like...
And then he realized...
I'm not getting up.
So, he just walks back to his bed.
And just goes back to sleep.
And I'm, like...
That's right, you whore.
You eat...
You eat when I wake up.
We are readjusting your schedule.
Toki, that's messed up.
Okay.
I feed him at 10.30 in the morning.
That's just two hours later, chat.
It's not like I'm starving him for the rest of the day.
I just need two more hours of sleep.
Like, I eat at 10.
That's late.
You eat on my...
It's two hours.
It's not like I'm fucking dragging it out to 12.
Oh, my God.
Poister, he eats wet food.
Poister, by the way, he fucking loves wet food so much that, like, when I used to feed him dry food, he, like, waits until, like, you know, I just scoop the food and then, and then put it in his, um, you know, in his bowl.
But he waits for me to, like, finish putting things, putting in the bowl.
That, for wet food, is like, gimme, gimme, gimme.
I have to, like, hold him off while I'm pouring food in his bowl.
Because he just, when I don't, he, like, sucks his head into the can.
I don't know.
He's, like, he's fucking ready.
Like, I have to literally use my other hand to hold him while he's, like, pushing against my hand, and, like, like, pushing against it and, like, trying to run towards the bowl while he's already at the bowl.
Like, it's because you're starving him, Doki.
Oh, yeah.
My giant-ass cat of white food and I'm starving him.
That, he's gonna recall this as trauma.
So, I have to, like, hold him and just pour, just pour the can and then, like, let him go.
Because the thing is, I can't give him the full can.
I have to do, like, um, no, I said wet food.
I have to, like, um, pour half and then, like, save the other half for, like, dinner.
Because he can't eat the full can.
Um, he is going...
He is going to die of hunger, Doki.
How dare you?
Dad will remember this.
It's the good shit.
But, yeah, that's basically the life update of, uh, dad so far.
Um, I am adjusting.
He's already adjusted.
He's having the time.
You know, I would say that he's technically living a better fucking life.
Because of all the shit that's going through.
Because now he's even more spoiled.
He has so much more to his life now.
Um, the wet food can't get more.
Yes, it can!
What?
I...
Papa Smurfs, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, how much more...
You know what?
I even Amazon ordered, like, a little playpen for him.
Because I was told we had to keep him.
Like, I...
Um, the dogs are telling me that he was getting more active and running around and stuff.
So I was like, oh shit, okay.
So I...
Amazon ordered those little, like, playpen gates.
So he can be, like, restrained in one area.
Like, you know, prison.
Um...
A little doggy prison for him.
So he won't...
I was scared.
Because I didn't want him to, like, run around.
And then I realized, like...
Huh.
Who am I kidding?
He doesn't give a fuck when I'm here.
He just sleeps.
I...
I guess he's, like, no family and no life.
So he, like...
All he does, like, you know, when I work is he just sleeps, like, in his bed.
So I was like, oh my god.
So, literally, I have this giant box.
Like, the box with, like, no sitter.
It's EP time.
Like...
So...
Um...
Basically, he's surprised right now.
Anyway.
Um...
So...
Uh...
I have this giant box sitting outside my door.
But I live in an apartment.
So, like, nobody steals, um...
In my...
On my floor.
Um...
The special thing about it is that, um...
Our keys are...
Are, like, hobs or whatever the fuck is called.
The things that goes beep.
And then you take the elevator.
It's, like, restricted to my floor only.
So...
Only people living on my floor can access, like...
Can access my floor.
So, like...
Um...
The fob.
Yeah, the fob.
So...
Um...
So I have this giant box of the doggie prison jail.
Just outside my door.
Because it's fucking huge.
It's, like, as tall as me.
Like, the box thing.
Um...
It's almost as tall as me.
So, like, I realized...
Dad...
Wasn't gonna fucking move.
Or, like, do anything.
So I've just been letting it sit outside for a week plus now.
I...
Because I was, like...
I don't wanna bring it inside.
It's so fucking big.
Like...
And I live alone.
So it's been sitting outside for a week now.
Because, like...
He's...
I'm not gonna unpack it.
Obviously.
Um...
But, like...
So, like...
Because I was, like...
Oh, he's just sleeping.
So, like...
I'll just put it...
I'll just...
I'll bring it in when I have to.
No, I'm not gonna return it.
Because what if I need it later, guys?
What if he needs to go to doggy jail later?
Like, I don't know that.
Like...
Um...
Andy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Turned 40 on Wednesday last week.
Can this old man get a happy birthday?
Of course you can!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Andy.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
I'm not a hoarder, guys.
I might have, like...
Seven plus boxes I have never unpacked.
But I am not a hoarder.
What else?
Okay.
Enough about that update.
What did I do in the last week?
Okay, so...
I know a lot of you guys are going through, like...
We're, um...
Getting desperate.
Um...
And because, obviously, like, you know...
Usually when I take a break, I wouldn't be gone for that long.
And I would, you know...
Do, like, a gorilla stream in between every so often.
But, obviously, I didn't.
Um...
I took that break to touch grass.
Yes!
I actually touched grass, um...
For...
Not the first time.
And I didn't get sick.
Yet.
Knock on wood.
I...
So...
Actually, I went to...
I went to some farm...
I went to the farmer's market.
I went to a night market.
And, um...
I actually, um...
Asked a few of my friends.
Uh...
They wanted to do an escape room together.
And I also did...
Yes, guys.
I have friends outside...
I have friends outside of the internet.
I might not have, like, talked to some of them for, like, years.
So, it was a little weird.
Where I was like...
Hey, it's been a long time...
Since we, like...
Interacted.
Um...
Hey...
Hi.
You wanna do an escape room together?
I was like...
Hey.
You wanna...
You wanna do an escape room?
We haven't talked in a long time.
But you wanna do an escape room?
I...
I just...
I wanted to do an escape room, okay?
I just wanted...
I did not do, like, rent a friend or some shit.
I have...
I have friends in real life.
I just haven't talked to them in maybe years.
But, like...
We...
We talked to each other after...
I did not escape the room.
I...
Um...
We failed...
Spetag...
We fucking...
Failed in the escape room.
Um...
Uh...
So, like...
Okay, by the way...
I would like you to know...
That, like...
We were, like...
Can we...
Me and my friends were, like...
We wanna do the easiest one.
And then...
Um...
And then the lady was, like...
There's this room.
And then...
I was, like...
Cool.
What is the success rate?
And then she was, like...
That's a 23% success rate.
And I...
So, I was, like...
Oh, cool.
Okay.
I was, like...
What?
What do you mean a 20?
That's your easiest one?
How the fuck was that the easiest?
Um...
There were three...
By the way, there was, like, three of us.
So...
The easiest one.
By the way...
I wasn't the one...
That fucked us over...
In the escape room.
Um...
We put one person...
One of the person was in charge...
Of cracking this specific puzzle.
Because each of us were, like...
Doing specific puzzles.
Me and my other...
Me and a friend...
Okay, we'll do friend A and friend B.
Me and friend A...
We figured out our puzzles.
Friend B...
For some fucking reason...
Was seeking forever...
In puzzle number three.
So, we were, like...
What the fuck is going on?
And they're, like...
I don't understand.
This is the right password.
And I was, like...
Okay, input the password.
And then she, like...
Inputed a password...
And then pressed the bell button.
I was, like...
What the fuck are you doing?
And she was, like...
I don't...
It's the bell button.
I was, like...
No, it's the fucking pound key.
You fucking idiot.
I was, like...
Have you not pressed codes before?
I was like, it's the pound key!
Have you never have a password?
Have you never entered a fucking gate code?
So she was like, it's me, I'm friendly.
No, no, I was the one!
I was like, what's the code?
And she was like, blah, blah, blah.
And I was like, beep, beep, beep, pound.
And then it unlocked.
Sorry, I meant the hashtag.
Fucking sorry, I meant hashtag.
The hashtag thing.
And then so, so I was, I obviously, I was like, oh my god.
She was literally stuck on that puzzle for so fucking long.
Checking it, double checking it, triple checking it.
And then I was like, I was like, she's like, no, this is the correct one.
I was like, are you sure?
She's like, yeah, but it won't work.
And then I, we like lost 20 minutes.
We, we lost, we lost 20.
And then I asked the lady.
I was like, how close were we?
How fucking close were we?
And she was like, you had three puzzles left.
I was like, I fucking, the stupid pound key.
This is why I had a 20% win rate.
Lord Kurosis.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I would like you to know, I did all my shit correctly.
I, I don't know.
It was apparently the easiest one.
I was like, I would like the easiest escape room, please, for the three of us.
And then she was like, oh, we'll do this one then.
And I'm like, how's success rate?
23%.
It's a team.
I don't know.
She was stupid.
Also, if you're watching this, I'm sorry.
But you know, you fucked up.
If you're watching this right now, you know, you fucking fucked up.
We told you, you fucked it up.
All two of us told you were the reason why we didn't make that escape room.
You know that we blame you.
We got two kids.
The call.
All two of us blame friend B.
But yeah, no, we didn't, we didn't success.
That's, you know, I haven't, by the way, I haven't done a, an escape room for like years now.
So like, that's why I just, I don't know.
I was like, what do I want to do?
So I was just Googling like things to do in the city.
And it was like, it was literally like, there was like laser tag and like the virtual, like reality shooters and stuff like that.
And then I saw, and then apparently there was like a ton of escape rooms around the city.
And then I was like, I'm going to do escape room.
I was like, I'm going to do it.
I'm going to do a fucking escape room.
I haven't done that shit in years.
And that's thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can try again in five years.
It takes in the five years it takes to talk to your friends again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wings.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine going back and find out that Friend B bumped that failure rate by a whole 2%.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Affiliant, thank you for the magenta soup.
Really glad you've been having a great time with friends while you're away.
Welcome back, Doki.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It was just really fun, like, just reconnecting with some of my older friends and everything.
We might have a...
Guys, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
I don't like female friend groups.
Too much drama.
The drama.
The great escape room drama.
And I was the one that dragged my friends into the escape room just so I could yell at them.
The escape room incident.
The escape room situation is crazy.
Doki had friends.
But yeah, I went to, like...
Oh, I even watched Thunderbolts.
I haven't been in a...
I wanted to watch Minecraft movie, but I wanted to go to a VIP theater.
So, the difference between a normal theater and a VIP theater is that you can drink.
In the VIP theater, you can drink.
And I really wanted to drink while watching a dumb movie.
So, the only movies that were playing was, like, Thunderbolt and, like, the others I don't fucking care.
So, I was like, alright, the only difference is the alcohol.
So, I was like, well, I want to watch a stupid fucking movie and, like, a cinema.
Because I haven't been in a cinema in a while now.
So, I was like, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna drink and watch a Thunderbolt.
And the thing is, I haven't, like, um...
I haven't watched Marvel films in a long-ass fucking time.
I was also, like, ten minutes late.
I was not pre-drinking, by the way.
I was just, like, ten...
I was just...
I didn't take into account of, like, time.
So, I was also, like, ten minutes late.
So, I missed, like, the first ten minutes.
And I, like, almost, like, going in, it was, like, in a fucking weird scene.
Where, like, I don't know, Yolana or whatever.
Like, I didn't even realize, like, Black Widow has a fucking sister.
Okay, this was my issue.
I had no idea who any of those characters were.
I... except for Bucky.
I...
I didn't even watch any movies where Bucky was in the film.
Other than, like, what is it?
Endgame.
Endgame was, like, the only movie I watched with Bucky in there.
And then, like...
And, like, so majority of my context about Bucky was literally Marvel Rivals.
So, like, I had zero idea who any of these characters were for Thunderbolts.
And, like, apparently, a lot of them appeared in, like, TV shows.
Like, Disney Plus TV show spin-offs.
Other movies.
And, like, all the other shit.
And I was like...
Because I was like, who the fuck are all these people?
I was so confused.
But, so, like...
And then there was...
Okay, I'll give you guys a spoiler alert.
Because, like, there was a lady on the poster with a cool-ass fucking mask design.
Um...
Okay, huge spoiler alert.
I thought she was gonna be an important character.
Part of the Thunderbolts movie.
Only because she was in, like, all the posters.
But she literally dies in the first 15 minutes.
I...
I was like...
Is she dead?
Like, in my head, I was like...
Is she...
I was like...
That's it?
I thought she would be more important.
She lives in all the posters.
She did not complete her task.
Yeah.
But, like...
Apparently, she was an important character in, like, one of the movies.
So...
So I was so...
I was so confused.
Um...
But, yeah.
They all, like...
Yeah.
She did not complete the task.
Apparently.
So, um...
I was very confused in the beginning of the movie.
Just because they were introducing, like, five plus characters that I didn't know existed in the franchise.
But they all showed up in different parts of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
And obviously...
Obviously, in the end, I knew who they were because the movie spent a lot of time building them up.
I like Bob.
Bob's my favorite character, honestly.
I think he's the...
He was the best character out of all of them.
I don't really care much about anybody else.
Bob's pretty cool.
I like him.
For those who are like, who's Bob?
You'll find out.
You'll know who Bob is.
And you'd be like, Bob's the best.
He's the go.
I don't...
Also, I don't know if it's because I enjoy the movie more.
Because I was drunk.
I was definitely drunk while watching Thunderbolts.
I ordered some fucking alcohol that had, like, vodka in it.
So, I was definitely drunk.
And I had nachos, too.
I ate nachos with my drink.
So, I don't know.
Personally, if you're like, was the movie good?
I don't know.
I was pretty drunk while watching the movie.
So, I had...
I personally had a good time watching the film.
Just because...
But I don't know if it's whether or not.
The movie was good.
Or, like, I was just having...
I was just having a good time drinking while watching.
Bob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gee, thanks, Doki.
I appreciate the show.
Oh, yeah.
I thought it was funny.
I like how someone's like, The children got sent to the Shadow Realm.
Okay, so, like, Bob's special power when he...
When depression gets him.
Um, is that he can send people to their, like...
So, like, people thought they died when they got sent, like, in the trailer.
And then, like, we were like, oh my god, are they dead?
Are they dead?
But no, like, um...
They get sent to, like...
Uh, they get sent to, like, the Shadow Realm.
Where you relive your, like, deepest, darkest, like, regret.
Or, like, personal, like, trauma.
But I was just thinking, if you rewatch your trauma over and over and over again, then it just doesn't matter anymore.
Like...
Like, at one point, you get desensitized to the trauma.
So, it's like, I feel like, you know, at one point, you'll be okay.
Like, obviously, I'm not a licensed therapist, so...
But I'm like, you know how it's gonna go at that point.
Like, you know, um...
It depends...
Obviously, yeah.
It depends on the trauma itself.
So, I was like, yeah, exposure therapy.
Exactly.
Um...
Um, so, like, you know, at first, people thought, like, they died.
But you just get sent to your own personal hell.
Um, and then, so, like, in one of the scenes...
Spoiler.
In one of the scenes, a child...
Like, the first instance of the Shadow Realm was that...
He's...
Um...
A child almost dies.
And then, one of the Thunderbolt characters comes over and saves the child.
And everybody's, like, clapping, like...
Yay!
Heroes!
And then, the child gets snapped.
And then, it was like...
And then, she, like, flattens on the ground as a shadow.
And everybody's like, what the fuck?
Just like...
So, you're like, oh, shit.
But the thing is, she's a child.
So, she has, like, no trauma yet at that point.
Because she's still, like, a child.
So, like, when, like...
Obviously, when they, like, save everyone...
The child just was, like, looking around as if she's so fucking confused as to what the fuck happened.
Like...
Um...
She was just, like...
Oh?
Oh, my God.
What happened?
Um...
Yeah, I was, like, her being sent into the void might have been...
Maybe...
Might have been her trip.
But she looked fine.
Afterwards, when, like, they freed her from...
From the void.
Because she didn't have much trauma.
Um...
Uh...
But, yeah.
Anyway, so...
Um...
That was my experience.
That was my experience with, um...
Thunderbolts.
I would have to say that...
It seems like a nice movie.
But I have no idea if it's a good movie.
Just because I was not sober.
That's why I went to a VIP theater.
That was the main reason why...
I...
I wanted...
I wanted to go to a VIP theater.
Because I...
I wish...
I wish Minecraft was still...
The Minecraft movie was still playing.
So I could, like, you know, drink while...
Drink while watching it.
But, sadly, it wasn't the theaters anymore.
So, yeah.
I heard everyone said it was a good movie.
Um...
I was like, when the fuck did Bucky became a fucking congressman?
I was so...
Like, because, obviously, there's, like...
It's built off of, like...
Stuff from previous movies.
And, like, from previous series.
It builds off of it.
So, like, at one point, they were like...
Bucky's now a congressman.
And I was like, who the fuck elected Bucky as a congressman?
And also, like...
The fact that...
Okay.
I know they're, like...
Spoiler alert.
Um...
Yeah.
He apparently became a congressman at one point.
And I was so confused.
I...
Apparently, he, like, went...
He only did one term of congress before he got, like, kicked out or something.
Or he got not re-elected.
I was so confused.
I...
There were so many things that happened.
And I was like, when did any of this happen?
Hmm.
But...
One thing confused me was...
Um...
So, they became the New Avengers.
Right?
They became the New Avengers.
But it was literally...
I thought it was really funny.
Because the Avengers...
The New Avengers were literally three Captain...
Three different versions of Captain America.
I was like, it was three different versions of Captain America.
I was like, that's so fucking stupid.
Captain America was so good...
That they just hired three of them.
And...
Um...
And, like, one of them was, like, Russia's Captain America during the communist era.
And I was like, why did we...
Why did we bring Captain Russia to the Avengers team?
I...
I was so confused.
I was like, wait, I don't...
I feel like...
I feel like the citizens would not want Captain Russia to be protecting America.
I...
Like, I was so...
I was so confused.
He's...
Oh my God.
But yeah, I thought it was really...
I thought it was really funny that it was three different versions of...
Three different versions of Captain America.
And...
I just thought it was really funny.
Because that's why...
Um...
And then the...
The...
After credits...
I'm sorry.
I'm just saying a lot of spoilers right now.
I'm saying a lot of spoilers.
But in the first after credits scenes...
They try...
They bring up the fact that the Avengers can be copyrighted.
And I was like...
Because like...
Sam Wilson...
The other Captain America...
You know...
Because like...
So now it's...
The fourth Captain America...
Is trying to trademark the Avengers...
So he can build his own Avengers team.
So it's like...
So we're trying to figure out like...
Which is the...
Yeah, they're gonna get DM...
They're gonna get...
The other Avengers teams...
Might get DMCA'd.
DMCA'd...
Because...
Sam Wilson...
The other Captain America...
Is trying to trademark...
Captain of...
Like...
The Avengers...
I wonder if he'll trademark Captain America too.
Because technically...
Steve Rogers...
Passed down the shield to him.
So Sam...
Is technically the next Captain America.
So I'm just wondering if he's gonna trademark Captain America...
So that...
They can't have three Captain Americas...
In the other...
It's a little confusing.
So there's...
In the end...
In the MCU...
There's...
Technically...
No...
There's five Captain Americas.
Because I forgot about Peggy.
I...
How many more...
Captain's can we have?
Because I forgot...
We have Peggy...
As the female Captain America.
So in...
In the MCU...
There's five Captain Americas.
And they're all...
I don't know...
Which one's the real Captain America anymore.
I don't...
I don't know...
Who...
Who is Captain America?
America...
Too many...
Captains...
I am the captain now...
I'm...
So yeah...
Like...
There's a lot...
I'm...
I'm very confused...
I'm very...
I'm so confused...
Um...
Where is...
Where is Captain Canada?
Um...
But yeah...
Too many tanks.
This team has too many tanks, guys.
We need to...
We need to change things up.
Oh yeah...
By the way, you guys didn't know...
This week I'm learning Elden Ring.
I have to learn...
You'll find out reason why...
Very soon.
I mean, some of you guys have some really good guesses.
Obviously, I can't say why...
But it'll be announced soon.
So I didn't really want to start Elden Ring...
This soon.
But apparently, I have to learn Elden Ring...
Mechanics...
For this thing.
So like...
Um...
We're gonna learn Elden Ring...
And then like...
Just figure this out as we go...
Um...
Anyway...
Also, we do have a special sponsor...
On Saturday.
Obviously...
I can't say what it is yet...
Because it has been announced.
There's a lot of things that...
The thing about having weekly schedules...
Is that...
I've found out...
That a lot of like...
Western sponsors...
And Western like...
Tournaments and stuff...
You...
They do announcements...
Really...
Late...
Like...
So it's like...
You can't...
Pre-announce things...
Earlier...
At the start of the week...
Before this thing happens...
So it's like...
Really difficult for me...
To just be like...
I'll tell you guys later...
So...
So I have to like...
Wait...
And then just wait...
Until...
Because a lot...
I realize...
A lot of them tend to announce it...
Um...
A lot later...
Before like...
Which is...
I...
I don't...
I'm not sure...
Reasoning why...
But I feel like it's very common...
In like...
NA...
Um...
To like...
Yeah...
It's like a self-drop and stuff...
So it's like how...
You know how streamers do like...
Early access streams...
And like...
You know...
Previews...
They don't tell you guys...
Like...
You know...
They don't give you guys an early warning...
It usually just happens on that day...
And be like...
Hey guys...
We're gonna be looking into this...
Like...
Right now!
But like...
I always have to be like...
Oh...
When can I announce this?
Because I have...
You know...
I make my schedule...
In advance...
I try to have like...
So you guys can...
Obviously I have fans from...
Around the world...
And like...
And a lot of people...
Rearrange their own schedules...
To like...
Match mine...
So like...
I have to...
I wanna announce it early...
And stuff like that...
So like...
Always be like...
Oh...
When can I say it?
Like...
Oh...
When can I talk about it?
And stuff...
Um...
Uh...
Yep...
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you...
Oh guys...
By the way...
Um...
I'm getting a new...
Two new emotes gonna be made...
I don't know when they'll be finished...
But one of them is like...
Is the...
I'm so happy for you emote...
And it's gonna be a dragoon...
Doing it...
Cause I know you guys really wanted...
I really wanted...
A...
A dragoon version of it...
That was that emote...
So...
Yeah...
I'm getting that main...
I don't know when it'll be finished though...
Mmm...
Other...
Oh my god...
Okay...
So I don't know if you guys saw this video...
I saw this video today...
And I asked...
Uh...
Frel...
If I could like...
Upload it onto my channel...
Because I love it so much...
You guys might have already seen it...
Cause I retweeted it...
But for those who like...
Don't follow Twitter...
I love this video...
It's so fucking funny...
I'm uploading it on my YouTube later...
Dance!
Dance for them!
Yes!
I asked if I could upload it...
If I could...
I could upload it to my channel...
And she said yes...
Um...
But I'm gonna...
I'm gonna upload that...
Later today...
Uh...
Ready to put on the show...
This is live footage...
Of me playing Luna Snow...
Um...
Someone...
Made an edit of it...
And then...
Frel animated the edit...
Um...
Uh...
So...
So I'll upload this...
After...
After this stream...
Because I love it so much...
Um...
By the way...
I got fucked over by Uber Eats again...
This week...
I'm...
I...
I've decided that...
I am swapping from Uber Eats...
And I'm gonna try...
I'm gonna try...
The Canadian version...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do the Canadian...
Um...
The Canadian version of it...
And for those who are like...
Oh, what's the Canadian...
We have our own...
Food app...
Called Skip the Dishes...
And...
Um...
I am...
I've...
I've had...
Um...
An Uber Eats driver...
Fucked me over...
Again...
So how did he fuck me over?
So...
Basically...
Um...
What happened was that...
I was ordering groceries...
Uh...
Because I...
Obviously like...
I needed groceries...
And I didn't wanna go to...
Um...
The place to get groceries...
Cause it's really far...
And I don't...
I have a car...
So I didn't wanna...
Walk all the way there...
And then walk all the way back...
With the groceries...
So...
I was ordering groceries...
And...
Um...
The first time...
I was...
Monitoring the app...
I was monitoring...
Yeah...
And then...
Um...
You know...
They were shopping my stuff...
And...
Uh...
They were shopping my stuff...
And then I saw like...
Well it wasn't just groceries...
I also was like...
Getting like...
Um...
What's the word called?
You know...
Toilet paper...
And tissues...
And stuff like that...
Like it wasn't just like...
Grocery stuff...
And...
So I was watching it...
And then they were buying...
Everything...
And then...
They got...
You know...
They were like...
Wrapping up...
And then the order...
Canceled...
And I was so confused.
I was like, what?
Why did the... And then I had no record of the order.
So it didn't show up.
I was like, what happened?
Like, it just disappeared.
I was like, do I get a refund?
I could go to the help desk to be like, what's going on?
Because the order fucking disappeared.
It wasn't even at my, like, past orders.
So I was like, okay.
I'm gonna reorder it.
So then I reordered my stuff.
Because I was like, what the fuck is going on?
And so I reordered my stuff.
And later, I got a pop-up and said, the order was cancelled.
So then I was like, what?
But like, okay.
And then I figured out that... But this was like an hour.
Like, not an hour.
30 minutes later, it popped up to tell me the old order was cancelled.
I thought that order was for my new order.
So I got really confused.
I was like, it got cancelled again?
So I went to the help desk this time.
And then they're like, oh, sorry.
This was for your first order, by the way.
Your current order is still in progress.
And... But don't worry.
Your card was not charged.
So I was like, okay.
But what the fuck happened?
And then the support desk was like, the guy that was paying for your order did not have enough money to pay for it.
And I was like, why did he take my order?
So he cancelled it because he got everything, went to the cashier, and didn't have enough money to pay for my order.
And I was like, why did he take it then?
Why would you take a grocery order if you can't pay for it?
I don't understand.
I was so confused.
I was like, you could take like...
You could take like the Uber Eats orders.
Why did he take my grocery order?
Like...
So...
So I was like...
I was so confused.
Like, if you're struggling, and don't have enough to pay for my groceries, then don't take it.
Like...
No, it was $50.
It was $50 Canadian dollars.
I was so confused.
Um...
Anyway...
So...
After that...
I reordered it again.
And it arrived this time.
But I got fucked over so much by Uber Eats that I'm swapping.
Because three times within two weeks of getting fucked over is like a little bit too many times.
Like...
And this was all within two weeks.
So I was just like...
I cannot...
I cannot deal with that.
My luck is way too bad.
So I'm not using Uber Eats anymore.
Um...
But yeah, I was like...
That's so sad.
I was like...
Bro, he is having it rough.
But also...
Bro, why did you take my order?
I don't ever understand.
I...
I thought...
I was like...
And then he cancels it.
Why couldn't a different person...
Why couldn't he just give it to a different person?
Like...
I don't know why...
He cancelled it too.
Why couldn't he just...
Say, I will take this order.
And then another person...
I had to reorder everything.
That was the worst part.
I had to like...
Reorder...
Everything.
And then like...
Um...
I had to reorder everything.
I had to remember what I ordered too.
Because obviously like...
He cancelled it.
So I don't have records of it.
It only showed up an hour later.
Um...
Anyway...
What else I was gonna say?
Oh yeah.
Also...
Guys, did you hear about the new Fortnite update?
Sorry, this is a weird segue.
Um...
It's...
It's a...
It's a fucking weird segue.
But I had to talk about the new Fortnite update.
Um...
So for those who don't know...
The new Fortnite update...
They added...
Darth Vader?
And then like...
So the voice actor for Darth Vader...
Passed away.
But he sold his voice...
To Disney.
So they could make AI...
An AI Darth Vader.
So...
Because of that...
Um...
Fortnite...
Decided to utilize...
The AI Darth Vader...
And he gets...
He...
I...
I saw some of the clips...
And he talks about...
Gooning...
And...
I...
I was like...
What the fuck?
Okay...
Let me...
I was like...
Yeah...
I saw...
Some of the clips...
Are...
Fucking...
Wild...
And then people...
And then...
The Fortnite was like...
This was not supposed to happen...
And...
I...
I'm trying to remember...
Like...
Um...
I'm trying...
I don't know where the clips...
I'm trying to find a clip right now...
But like...
Um...
You see something...
Let me see if I can find it...
There's like a clip of him...
Talking about gooning and edging...
And I was like...
Oh my god...
What did they think was gonna...
I don't...
I don't know...
But clearly...
They did not think this through...
Clearly...
If you put...
Especially in Fortnite...
Of all games...
Like...
They're...
We have some gamers in Fortnite...
We...
We have...
Oh yeah...
And also...
He gets the races too...
I was like...
Holy...
Guys...
I don't think Disney's gonna let...
I don't think Disney's gonna let Fortnite do any...
I don't do any more...
Any more of this...
Um...
I'm trying to find the gooning clip...
That one was wild...
I...
I think that one was wild...
Oh yeah...
I like the Hatsune Miku...
Wait...
Let me find the...
Miku clip...
That...
Miku clip was funny too...
Let's see...
Here...
This one's my favorite too...
I...
I like...
Wait...
I'm gonna try and see if I can find the...
Goon one...
That one's important...
I'm trying to find the Goon clip guys...
Okay...
Let me see if...
Was it like...
Vader...
Edgy...
God...
My fucking search bar...
Wait...
I'm literally looking up...
Fortnite...
Vader...
Edgy...
Okay...
Don't...
I...
Look...
This is important...
It was...
Really funny...
It...
You don't understand...
It was...
Really...
Funny...
Okay...
Oh...
There you go...
I found another one...
This one's pretty good...
Oh...
Here...
Here's the...
Here it is...
Guys...
I found it...
Here...
I'll even...
Guys...
Turn on...
I'll turn this on...
Just for you guys...
So you can hear...
Darth Vader...
Say this...
Edging...
And...
Gooning...
Edging...
And...
Gooning...
Edging...
And...
Just remember...
He passed away...
And...
Then he sold his voice to Disney...
So this could happen...
Like...
I...
This is not my fault...
This is...
Alright...
This one too...
I like this one...
This one's funny...
Here...
Listen to this...
Hatsune Miku...
Your training is complete...
Wait, where is that?
No!
Okay, I don't know if I can find...
I can find Vader and Hatsune Miku fucking killing the lobby.
Because that shit was good.
Oh, yeah, there's this one.
Wait, I'll show you this one.
Hatsune Miku is hit.
Find cover quickly.
No, Hatsune Miku!
No!
Someone protect me!
Oh my god.
No, not Miku!
Someone save Miku!
Too much.
Bro, he just... Bro, Darth Vader just really, really likes Hatsune Miku.
You don't understand.
He just...
In fact, I will say there's not enough emotion for Hatsune Miku.
But yeah, that's basically like...
So yeah, Disney's not happy.
But like, when has Disney ever been happy?
Not gonna...
Disney is usually never happy.
Um...
I mean, it was their fault for like...
I don't know why they thought that was a good idea.
Fortnite of all places.
Like, there are some fucking gamers in Fortnite too.
So...
Um...
So it's crazy that like...
They thought that, you know...
You know, you could say in the boardroom...
They must be like...
Oh my god, guys.
That is a great idea, Jerry.
We should definitely use that AI feature of Darth Vader.
So like, it could be tailored to each user's experience.
What a good idea, Jerry.
What could go wrong?
But then they sort of forgot...
That...
Gamers are like...
Fucked up people.
And like...
I can say it cause I'm a gamer.
Um...
Our imagination...
Knows no bounds.
If we...
People can get really creative.
Even if you try to put restrictions in there.
People can get very creative...
On trying to make them say really bad things.
...
He was laughing.
So...
Umm...
So I thought that was really silly.
Cause I was like...
Everywhere in my timeline.
And everybody was...
Everybody was like...
Try to...
Try to be like...
Let's see what we can get Darth Vader to say!
He nei nei nei nei nei Uh...
Yeah, people will spend hours to try and break the filter.
And like...
Like, um, they succeeded.
And Disney is, like, very, very mad.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, for the member goons.
Um, I feel... Today, I feel really generous.
So, I'm gonna send... I'm gonna show the preview of the... I'm gonna show the preview of next month's wallpaper.
By the way, May's wallpaper is out now.
So, not member goons.
I'm sorry.
By the way, this wallpaper was for January.
Just so you guys know.
This was the missing wallpaper that we never got.
So, like, I know next month's wallpaper is... We're gonna get, like, two wallpapers for June.
I think.
Because, like, obviously, one is, like... Gonna be more appropriately themed to June.
But, like, this was supposed to be January.
Wait.
So, we're releasing... We're releasing a winter wallpaper.
Um, in... In... In June.
Um...
So, this was supposed to be the new... Uh, so, yeah.
Look forward to that.
This was for the mem... Uh, for members.
But, as you don't know, um, each month, um, in, uh, members, I release a free wallpaper for everybody.
So, this is another night... Light mode wallpaper.
I'm sorry.
We... We do have some dark wallpapers, too.
For the... For those who don't want to get blinded.
Uh, oh, yeah.
This is for Australia.
You're right.
Australia goons.
We have a wallpaper for you.
So, you can relate.
Uh...
So, these are for, um...
This is for the member goons.
Uh...
Anyway.
Oh, Mike!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The real message of the movie.
Nerf Captain America.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But, it was nice to stream again.
Oh, my God.
I, uh... I really miss streaming.
It has been quite a while.
Um, whenever, you know, whenever I don't stream, I always forget what it's like to stream again.
So, it's great to be able to stream again for you guys.
To talk to you guys.
Give you guys some life updates.
About what the fuck was going on in my life.
In general.
Uh, D4.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bucky is 110 years old.
Just young enough for U.S.
Congress.
Jesus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, I realized my super chat records, like, just stopped working.
So, I need to refresh it real quick.
So, I can see...
The... Oh, yeah.
Definitely.
I've not seen these super chats.
Uh, Rodrigo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So happy to have you back.
Where else would I get my unhinged AI updates?
Love your wallpapers.
They're always so cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, Fudge Stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A reminder that George Lucas hired a guy who did Chad Vader parody voices...
Videos to voice Darth Vader for Forces Unleashed.
Now, we're listening to a dead celebrity talk about gooning...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't understand why we couldn't just get an impersonator.
Okay, I understand money.
Never mind.
Sorry, guys.
I understand money.
Capitalism.
Because it's cheaper to do it instead of hiring an impersonator.
Because I was like, we've had impersonators for Mickey Mouse and Bugs Bunny and all that shit.
So I was just like, wait, why are we using AI to do Darth Vader's voice?
I just think it's not even that natural.
That's my biggest issue.
Not my only issue.
Obviously, we're denying voice actors money right now.
Sorry, guys.
That is not the only issue about it not sounding real.
There's a lot of other issues.
But like, it doesn't even sound like real.
That's like my problem for me.
Is that it just sounds so bad.
And like, I have that same issue with people like using with them using AI to recreate dead or like de-age actors.
Like, you know how like, what was it?
In The Mandalorian, they did like the AI thing where they like de-aged Luke Skywalker in The Mandalorian.
And then it just looks so fucking weird.
But they got an impersonator.
Yeah, they de-faked Luke.
But they also spent money on a body double.
And the body double looked more like Luke than the de-fake of Luke.
So I was like...
So confused.
I was like, why didn't you just use the body double?
It looked just like him.
It's just...
It was so...
Weird.
The guy...
Like, literally think that...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try you guys.
I saw it.
I was like, he looks just like him.
Why did you de-fake him?
I don't understand.
It was...
It's just...
It was weird.
Like...
Like, I...
I just...
I don't understand.
Let's see.
Like, yeah, his eyes might not be as big.
But, like...
He...
At least...
At least it doesn't look unnatural.
Like...
Mark Hamill probably...
I don't know.
I don't know if Mark Hamill has a clause.
Has, like, the...
The...
What's his name?
Dwayne the Rock Johnson clause.
Which word he can never lose.
That shit's fucking weird.
That shit's...
Like...
You can see...
Okay.
I think it's funny that, like...
Look...
Like, I don't understand!
I don't...
I don't understand!
Why do you need to de-fake this?
I...
Just edit it a little bit!
Alright.
Here you go.
Let me show you guys.
Like...
Yes!
This just makes it more expensive!
This...
Like...
I feel like you're just...
Making it more expensive.
I...
Yo, and then they de-faked him.
Right after.
Just...
Makeup!
Just do makeup!
Guess which one's the de-fake?
Like...
The answer might not surprise you!
The...
Yeah!
Because...
You know why...
How...
De-fakes never work?
It's because like...
Maybe eventually it will.
Because technology evolves.
Um...
But it's because...
Deep fakes and AI...
Can never get lighting correct.
Because lighting is one of like...
The hardest things...
To get correct.
And the reason why...
Like...
Um...
The reason...
I also know a lot of this...
Because I used to watch Corridor Digital a lot.
But that's like...
What makes it uncanny.
It's because...
It's so hard...
To get realistic lighting.
But also because...
Studios...
Do not give 3D artists...
Or like...
Um...
Special effects artists...
Enough time...
To recreate...
Like...
Real lighting.
Um...
You can say like...
Well that's not true.
In Pirates of the Caribbean...
Um...
They were able to do so many things...
With special effects.
Like Davy Jones...
And like his ship and everything.
And the light...
And none of it ever looked uncanny.
But do you know how many years...
They spent on Pirates of the Caribbean...
On that one fucking movie?
Like...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha...
That shit...
They had like...
So much time...
To actually like...
Um...
Make that work.
But nowadays...
Like a lot of special effects movies...
Um...
Special effects and movies...
They make them be like...
We need this done by...
Like...
We need this done in like...
3 months.
So we can get it released during Christmas.
So...
Um...
So that's why...
Everything looks...
A lot...
That's why you can tell like...
Special effects...
Have gotten worse...
Over the years.
Because we're not given enough time...
To like...
Create...
Um...
To create...
The...
Create the things that they want to make.
And so like...
People are just going through crunch time.
I mean...
This looks fucking garbage.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I was like...
I don't understand!
The body double looked fine!
It's just his eyes!
Which you can like...
Put makeup on...
And make them pop out more.
It's literally just his eyes that make it like...
He's not...
Doesn't look like Luke in a way...
But...
That can be fixed.
That...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
No!
You know what was the worst one?
The worst one was the...
Was the...
The scene I saw...
In Black Panther...
I never watched the...
Uh...
Black Panther movie...
Guys, I never watched a lot of Marvel...
Marvel movies...
But I haven't watched the Black Panther movie...
Where like...
There was a fight scene...
That you could tell...
The CGI...
Was like...
Not the greatest...
I don't know which movie...
I don't know if it was the first one...
Or the second one...
But like...
Um...
But it was like...
Where there was like...
There was a...
I saw it in the Corridor Digital...
Movie...
Not movie...
I saw it on Corridor Digital...
Where they were showing it...
And I was like...
What the fuck was the CGI?
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
I was like...
I saw the CGI!
And then they fixed it...
In the...
Apparently they...
They fixed it in the Blu-ray version...
So there's like...
A video comparison...
Of like...
The Blu-ray...
Of the Black Panther edition where they fixed the CGI versus the original with the... Wait, let me see if I can find it.
Black Panther fight scene CGI.
Let's see if I can find it.
It was crazy.
I was like, what the... Oh my god!
Oh, it looks just as bad as... Okay, for those who are curious, this is what it used to look like.
I couldn't believe that was actually from the movie.
It looks like... You know what this reminds me of?
It looks like a PlayStation 2 cutscene.
It looks like...
Like, I can't... Yes, that's it!
You're right!
Oh, that's bad!
Yeah.
That is very generous.
Why didn't... But this was in Black Panther.
It's so bad!
But that was like... And then, um...
They were saying that... Oh wait, here's a better clip of it.
Here's a...
Here's a better clip of the fight scene.
Here.
It's just... Why are they so shiny?
I don't understand!
Why... I love this Black Panther PS2 coming out in 2020 December.
Wow, what is this game coming out for PlayStation 2?
Like, I'm like...
Why are they so fucking shiny?
I... I don't understand!
Um... Anyway...
So they got like...
They... In Corridor Digital...
They got like... I don't watch Corridor Digital anymore because they got...
I don't know... I just... I don't think I just... I... I wasn't as interested in the kind of content they were making anymore.
Um... But... Um... They had a series where it was like...
Special... CGI...
Effects... Special Effects...
Reacts...
Where like... They get like...
Um... Actual...
They get like... Actual like... CGI people...
Who worked on big movies.
Um... Yeah... VFX React... Yeah...
They did like... VFX... VFX...
Reacts...
Where they get like... People who worked on these movies...
To talk about...
How it happened.
And then the guy was just like...
We were not giving enough time.
And he was just like, yeah.
They said we have to complete this video, this movie by X amount of days.
And yeah, we did not have enough time.
Oh, don't get me started on Lilo and Stitch.
I was so sad.
They got rid of Jumba.
Who they got rid of?
They got rid of... Not Jumba.
They got rid of... Oh my god.
They got rid of... God, what was his name?
His name is like... Captain Gontu.
Captain Gontu is... He's the main villain.
Also, John, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
They got rid of Captain Gontu, the shark guy.
They got rid of... I was so confused.
I was like...
I don't understand.
No, they did.
They removed him and...
They removed him.
The main villain, by the way, from the live-action movie.
I was so fucking confused about it.
And... Because like, they just recently announced it.
Also, like, Jumba and Pleakley are so ugly.
I'm sorry.
I need to show you guys.
Um...
I'm sorry.
By the way, um...
Trigger warning for what they look like.
They're so fucking ugly.
Trigger warning for what...
What does Jumba and Pleakly look like in the live action?
Like, what are you trick- what's the warning?
Everything.
That's just it.
Oh my god.
What place?
No way.
Jumba and Pleakly.
But the thing that made me so sad...
Is that...
Pleakly doesn't cross-dress anymore.
Okay, they- okay, so...
So there's like...
So...
I was so sad because you know like the whole days they wear like really stupid disguises.
And everything to like fit into the...
Fit into like the human world.
But instead...
What I was so sad was that...
Like...
Um...
Yeah, they cut out the costumes.
So instead...
They do like...
Like...
Human...
Holograms.
And I was like...
Boo!
So now they're like the...
It's like the men in black...
Um...
You know, disguises that they do for aliens.
And I'm just...
I'm just a little sad because like it...
You know, it was so iconic, you know?
Give us...
Give us a cross-dressing alien!
Boo!
She was slay!
She bleakly walked so RuPaul's Drag Race could run!
Boo!
Shame!
I was like...
Um...
So true...
We want our diva pack!
I want girl boss...
Legally!
Um...
But yeah, so...
I was like...
I just thought...
I think it was funny...
That like...
Um...
I thought it was funny that...
You know...
The whole thing about their disguises...
Was that it was so bad...
But it still worked.
Like...
That's the silly part.
But now they're actually doing like the men in black...
Like...
Costumes and stuff.
So they're like...
Um...
So like they're more realistic.
But it...
That's what's what made it funny.
It was like...
How did these disguises work?
It's so bad.
To be fair...
Their alien forms are really fucking ugly though.
Like...
To be fair...
This is not...
I don't wanna look at this.
To be fair...
I...
I don't...
I don't wanna look at it.
So I don't...
Maybe it was a good choice...
That they decided to make them more human?
No!
Yeah!
Put it away!
There was concept art of their cut human...
Oh, was there?
Wait!
Lila...
And Stitch...
Live action concept art...
Human...
Disguise...
I'm typing so much for...
Oh my god!
I see it!
Slay!
Slay...
Um...
But yeah...
I don't know...
Apparently they were like...
Not...
They wanna see what...
If...
Lila and Stitch is like...
Their last...
Live action...
So if it bombs...
They're never doing live action again...
Because Snow White did...
So terribly...
Hello...
No!
Okay, but like...
Okay, what was it?
Snow White...
Line...
I fucking love that line...
I fucking love that...
Video...
Uh...
Gee...
They were saying that like...
Snow White did so fucking poorly...
That they do not wanna do...
Live action anymore...
Okay, was it the evil...
Queen...
Line...
I need to find that video!
It was so funny...
It was...
When...
When she was in that...
Um...
Okay...
What was it?
Gal...
Go...
That...
Snow White...
Line...
I should've bookmarked it...
Things that...
That makes me laugh...
No, no...
There was a...
Funnier...
There was an...
Even funnier line...
From...
Gal Gadot...
In...
Snow White...
Where she was in front of a mirror...
And she had to say a line...
And I was like...
Yes, girl!
Give me nothing!
Yes!
I love nothing!
Keep giving it to me!
I saw that...
One scene...
And I was like...
Jesus Christ...
I can't see no fire...
And I'm like looking on Twitter...
It's like she was in like...
A mirror...
Like not the magic mirror...
She was like sitting on a counter...
And then she said a line...
And then...
Yes!
Give us less!
Haha!
Come on!
You can...
You can always give me less!
You always...
Make...
Give me less!
Alright, let's see...
And I remember the...
The tweet was like...
How did the...
Background actor...
Like...
How is the background actor...
Able to like...
Not react to this?
learns!
Hahahaha!
Aaaah!
Okay, wait.
I'll let you guys hear this.
Wieher, okay hear this!
This is like...
A compilation...
Of like...
Her worst...
Voice...
uh...
Her worst acting!
Kaleel...
I Oh my god.
Fuck it.
Okay, wait.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
I found it.
Here we go.
Champagne.
To fill the Nile.
Kaleel, no.
Next Lord, you're putting yourself and everyone else in grave danger.
I need you to give me the stone.
What happened to it?
What did you say?
So exciting.
Very interested to find the man who bought those.
Why should I help you?
Because we're asking you nicely.
Just tell me what it costs to get away from me.
Name a price.
I'll buy the whole damn boat if I have to.
Who are you?
The last of... Yes, queen!
Give us nothing!
But who?
Enough.
I said enough as Anna...
I said enough.
Bro, what the fuck?
This is our duty.
You have no idea what kind of power you're doing.
Enough champagne to fill the Nile.
Where the fuck is that from?
I need to know.
Enough champagne to fill the Nile.
What the fuck is this movie?
Death on the Nile?
Alright.
Death on the Nile.
Okay.
Box office.
How?
Okay, wait.
Budget.
No.
Enough champagne.
It had a 90 million dollar bunch of...
Jesus Christ.
And no champagne to fill the Nile.
What was that?
Oh my god.
If I get...
If this stream gets DMCA'd, I'm sorry.
I had to play...
I had to play this...
Play it for you guys.
I had...
80 mil...
80 million dollars was for that one line delivery right there.
Enough champagne...
To fill the Nile.
Alright.
Oh man.
Sorry.
I had to...
I'm sorry.
She's dead already.
It's unironically a good film.
Damn.
I feel like if they casted any other actress other than Gal Gadot, it might have been an even better film.
I mean...
Bro...
I feel like...
Look, I don't...
I'm not a very good voice actor.
When it comes to like...
Um...
When it came...
Comes to like actually voice acting something.
But I feel like...
At least I'm not at that level.
You know?
At least...
At least like...
I have a little bit more emotion than that.
Okay.
Sorry.
I got like a little sidetracked on my...
Um...
Gal Gadot.
I don't even know how we got together.
I don't even know how we even got to...
How we even got there.
Um...
Oh yeah.
I was talking about movies.
Um...
Uh...
But yeah.
Um...
Everyone...
I don't watch movies.
Oh yeah.
I watched...
What is it?
There's a new season.
Um...
What is it?
Sex, love, robots?
Was that it?
No.
What was the full...
It's not sex, love, robots.
It's...
It's not...
Love...
Oh no.
It's love, sex, and robots.
Wait.
Is it that?
No way.
Sorry.
Love, death, and robots.
I don't know why I keep thinking it's sex, love, and robots.
It's not the first time.
It's love, death, and robots.
I watched the new season of love, death, and robots.
And I will tell you, it's the black mirror effect.
Where, um...
Where...
It's really bad.
It's not...
The new season sucks a lot.
Because, like, um...
It's just more...
The new season is more like...
It's more like...
Animation showcase...
Than, um...
It's an animation showcase...
Rather than an actual, like...
You know...
Actual, like, storyline for it.
I know, like, in the first...
Two seasons.
The first two seasons were really good.
Where they showed...
They mixed between the two.
So there's no...
There's barely any, like...
Story focused, um...
Story focused, like...
Episodes in there.
I'm only halfway through, though.
I'm...
I'm halfway through love, death, robots.
But, like...
The first episode, I was so confused.
Because I was like, where's the love?
Where's the death?
And where are the robots?
Because love, death, robots is like...
Each episode had at least one thing.
About love, death, or robots.
And the first episode is literally, like...
An animation showcase...
Of...
Red Hot Chili Peppers.
Like...
That's really it!
It was just...
It was just a music video...
For Red Hot Chili Peppers.
I was like, wait...
That's it?
That's where...
There's...
It was just a concert.
I was so confused.
It was literally a music video for...
For them.
For...
Um...
For one of their songs.
Oh yeah!
No!
There was one guy that dies in the audience!
I guess...
Wait, you're right!
It was like...
One guy that dies in the audience!
Because people were like...
So excited!
But...
And that's the death!
The one death that counted!
Uh...
Yeah!
I forgot about it!
I was so fucking...
I was so fucking confused!
I was like...
What the fuck?
Where...
Where is...
Oh...
What?
That's it?
That's the story?
Um...
No, I watched Secret Level.
It sucked.
I think Secret Level was not great.
It was incredibly hit or miss.
The episodes are either incredibly short.
Or like...
It was just...
Like...
It was just not good.
I was...
I honestly just did not...
I did not enjoy Secret Level.
The...
I didn't think...
Um...
I felt like a lot of the episodes were like...
Incredibly short.
And then like...
Uh...
The Mega Man was so fucking short.
I was not...
I was not expecting...
Um...
The Mega Man one to be so short.
Because I felt like...
I...
It was...
I was like...
Wait, that's it?
Um...
I feel like there was only like...
Two episodes that were good.
I heard the Warhammer...
I don't think I got to the Warhammer one.
Um...
But I heard the Warhammer one was...
Oh wait, no, I did.
I got to the Warhammer one.
I also like...
Didn't...
Didn't really watch.
Um...
I don't remember much of it.
It was just like...
It was so...
It was so weird.
I think like...
I just didn't think they did it really well.
In general.
Um...
The Pac-Man one was based off of their new game.
The new...
Um...
I just didn't remember it very well.
Warhammer Secret Level.
I just knew like...
It was just not... the secret level was just not as good as I expected.
Oh wait!
No, I remember.
I remember.
The animation was really good for this one.
No, I remember now.
I remember the Warhammer one.
But I didn't enjoy secret level that much just because a lot of the episodes were big misses.
There was only like one or two that was good, but you have to like dig through the trenches to find a good one.
Um, but like, yeah, I don't know.
Like, I feel like people... the anthology series for it, I like...
Like, you know how I feel like Love, Death, and Robots did the whole like hiring animators to make like their unique story for each one.
And then other places started copying them.
But like, oh my god, the longer they do it, the worse it gets.
It's just, I feel like there's no quality control anymore to it.
But, oh yeah, speaking of Netflix, Sesame Street is now coming to Netflix.
Wow!
That was, I thought that was really cool.
Because they don't, they didn't cancel Sesame Street.
But they're also, people were really worried because they're like, oh...
Oh no, they're gonna, like, kids have to pay Netflix now to watch Sesame Street.
But it's still gonna be on the PBS.
It's still gonna be on PBS.
It's just that, um...
Um, it's just that Netflix is helping fund, helping with funding the shows now.
Which will be like, I think that's okay.
Just because of the fact that it's either that or get canceled.
So, um...
So, like, I'm glad that Sesame Street is...
Like, I'm glad that Elmo's not homeless, you know?
I'm...
I'm glad, I'm glad Elmo is not homeless.
Yay!
Um, what happened to PBS?
Um, funding.
They don't have enough funding right now.
So, that's why they were shopping the shows around.
And Netflix decided to pick it up.
Speaking of shopping shows around, Gumball is getting a reboot on Disney slash Hulu.
Which was crazy to think about.
But to be fair, um...
Warner Brothers is not doing very well right now.
So, I'm not surprised.
I...
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Um...
I have a long, long, long week ahead of me.
So, um...
So, I'm gonna call it here.
It's really great to talk with my Dragoons again.
I had a great time hanging out with everybody.
Talking again with you guys.
Giving you guys a live update.
And just hanging out with all of you guys.
You guys always make it so fun.
And I love just talking with my Dragoons.
I miss you guys!
You know I do.
You know I miss hanging out with you guys.
And I hope you guys miss hanging out with me.
Um...
But yeah!
Thank you everybody for coming to the stream!
Hi guys!
Welcome to the Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
We're gonna be back to a regular scheduled week.
Um...
My schedule's already out.
So you know like tomorrow is Super Mario Mon.
So we're gonna go into that.
Um...
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you step for me, head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
I have to walk Dad now.
Um...
Because I'm a little late for his little walkies.
Just a little late!
Um...
So I'm gonna go walk Dad now.
But...
I really appreciate being back!
And I hope you guys miss me as well!
So...
Uh...
Thank you again for all the super chat!
All the support!
All the memberships!
I really, really appreciate it!
And I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!
Oh!
Secret ending!
I forgot to say!
And I said it on Twitter!
But I wanna say thank you again for all the support!
Especially when I took that week break off!
And all the vouchers and everything!
And all the outpouring love and support!
Um...
When I had to take that break!
It really does mean a lot!
I was really scared and nervous during that!
And so...
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it everybody!
Bye bye everyone!
Bye!